this is my first series okay I've got a
new series here I'm going to call them
series alpha
that's an alpha yes I am serious
okay now series alpha is very similar to
Series G okay wheeler minor difference
still it starts off with one still goes
to a - but the numbers will change so
I'm going to go like this so the numbers
are going to increase in value okay now
do you think like I'm like before
without 1 minus 1 plus 1 minus 1 plus 1
do you think we can assign a value to
this I think we can in a similar way
that we did here okay the key will be
how do I use the original series in a
way that makes sense of this okay well
watch I'm there double this right you
know equations if you do something once
I go to the other right so if I double
this side it stands to reason that I
should double the other side right now
there's a couple of different ways you
can do this I can just double all these
numbers I could write 2 minus 4 plus 6
minus 8 and so on and that would be true
okay but I can do it in a more
interesting way I'm going to write the
original series there's the first one
alpha okay and then I'm going to add it
again but in a different spot you can
add it here and it's actually vitally
important that you write it where it is
because otherwise I'll be very hard to
see what's going on
okay now I've just I just moved it over
it's sort of staggered if you like okay
but you can see what's going on here but
I can there's two of these alpha of
series here right but I can pair up the
different terms right I'm not going to
pay off the first terms together and
give you two four and six and eight I'm
going to pair this first term up watch
leave it then I'm gonna pair this second
term with the first term what do you get
you get minus 2 plus 1 which is minus 1
right yeah
plus three minus two guys plus 1 minus 1
plus 1 - okay hold on I recognize this
guy - right that's that's the series I
started with but I also know what that
series is equal to that's a half his
interview
allegedly that's a half so so if I want
to know what the actual she odd divided
again no problems that's a quarter
really have I made you think yet
okay hold onto your hats because he's
the last step he's the last step and I'm
really gonna bend your brain there are
three stages here ready stated the first
step was that
grandi series is gone ok second step was
this related series which you can see
has a relationship okay here's the last
series I'm just going to call it yes
okay and done it doesn't look well looks
pretty ordinary compared to the other
ones right looks decidedly gorgeou now
by the way by the way the series I
started with and then this series right
they had some alternative business
happening right and so that's kind of
what let us get a value at the end do
you think we can get a value for this
hmm now I'm going to do this again on
the count of three okay I want you to
look at this and I want you to settle in
your mind it could be wrong it's fine
mathematicians are wrong all the time
that's why they discovered cool stuff
okay but I want you to see what you
would take what do you think this whole
thing would be equal to them on the
count of three I'm gonna ask you all
said it once okay you ready
okay think about it in your head count
of three one two three
not a bad guess
yes because it's going to keep on
growing forever right guess what I've
got news for you
the question is how will I show you
well I label all these points to show
love this room I'm going to take this
sum and if I got it right I am going to
subtract this alpha series is going take
it off so again I'm going to write this
very carefully okay here's my original
one this is the sum of all the counting
numbers and by the way it's actually
important that you write quite a few of
them so don't you start don't did you
stop at three or four okay right right a
few of them out okay
okay at least a theme now I'm going to
subtract this series in here I'm going
to write it directly beneath a coyote to
rub that up properly
subtract this series looks like this one
minus two plus three minus four six plus
seven and so okay now just like before
we have some brackets to deal with right
but we can deal with brackets there
problems is a minus sign out the front
what does it - I do
it flip some off we saw this before okay
no problems okay so here's my S all of
the counting numbers there okay and then
here's what happens when I subtract this
series okay I start with a minus one
then I get a plus two what happens to
the three it's minus three plus four
minus five
+6
sorry all right Matt sedating right yeah
that's right forever
okay hmm what's happening
am I missing her I'll show you this one
this one no no I love you oh I see what
you mean that is a plus isn't it yeah
cool okay what happens here yes I'm
serious canceling isn't there right how
many terms cancel I've got uh the odd
terms cancel that's exactly right the
ones cancel the threes cancel
five sevens so what do you get left with
what do you get left with well by my
count I get a four and then an eight and
then a 12 what are these this is this
year's this guy but four times bigger
every term is four times bigger is it
not so this is four times this oh isn't
that hold on hold on we subtracted
something and it got bigger what does
that mean I'll show you what it means
look look look we we know what we know
what s alpha is this song it's a quarter
it's quite so I'm just gonna take that
outside all right yeah happy with that
how do I get this I want to know what
this thing is equal to right okay how do
I rearrange this thing looks to me like
I should take 1s over here subtract this
from both sides okay
looks to me like I get 3x equals
negative 1/4 so I should divide by 3
right right
5 divided by 3 I'll get back here I'll
get back to this this boring infinity
series right oh wait he's not infinity
after all have I made you think yet now
you can go off set and such in fact go
ahead and gotta look on um if you if
you're really that unable to go past the
first couple of results on Google go and
look for the Wikipedia article that's
named negative 1 over 12 and you will
find this proof and quite a bit
discussion it's a controversial result
of course it's a controversial result
how can you add on a whole bunch of
positive numbers not only get a negative
but get a negative fraction you're fired
here you clearly didn't figure I met
must have made a mistake somewhere right
right well you don't scrutinize like I
said I did not make up this proof it's a
well-known thing the question is what
does it all mean